85 so your birthday is actually next
month what will you do on your actual
birthday my family will be there my my
daughter and grandkids will come in from
Vermont and my son and his wife and
Child live in Los Angeles and a few
friends will come over and we'll just
we'll have a quiet time you
reached her with your trainer and said
yep Jane Fonda still works out I do
what's the workout regimen like slow
when you're when you're almost 85 the
the Mantra is slow
and obviously I don't use the same
heaviness of Weights that I used to
what's important is to keep moving you
know to keep yourself flexible to keep
building strength you know every day
that I climb into one of those High cars
that are you know or I'm backing out of
a driveway and I'm so grateful that I've
stayed strong and flexible do you ever
break out your old workout tapes no
there are a few that I probably could do
but
um no I just I had my shoulder replaced
nine months ago so you know a lot of
what I do has to do with getting a lot
of mobility in my arm and and you know
it's it's pretty good 80 for Brady the
trailer drops next week what are we in
store for oh it's really good yeah it's
very good it's very funny it's poignant
it was just a thrill towards me Lily
Tomlin Sally Field and Rita Moreno I
just loved working with those four women
we had such a good time Tom Brady's so
nice seems dare I say humble it was a
wonderful experience it's been shown to
audiences and they love it it's going to
be a big hit I've seen the finals yeah I
really like it Tom Brady can act I can
tell you I was surprised he can you
didn't have to tell him get on your mark
or do this no well he was sitting on a
bench the whole time the scene was with
Lily not me I had a scene with
Gronkowski oh that was funny he is fun
he's so tall I stayed away when he was
when Tom was filming with Lily because I
didn't want to make him self-conscious
but when I saw it I was quite impressed
yeah
accomplished so much done so much what
else is on your list that you want to
accomplish that you want to do see my
grandkids get old enough so that I go
out knowing that they're going to be
okay that would be important but you
know my work on the climate is going to
be I'll be doing that until I drop how
old are the grandkids now well I have
one that's a junior in college one
that's a freshman in college and one
that's three years old
oh and what do they think about Jane
Fonda as their grandmother I know my
little three-year-old grandson
um he likes Grandma you look amazing as
always but recently you did share some
very serious health news how are you
doing today I'm doing fine you know the
week that I get chemo is challenging you
get you get tired but then after that
week it's great I've been traveling
campaigning with climate candidates yeah
yes you have you've been very busy doing
that what if the messages of love and
support from your fans meant to you
means a lot to me it moves me very very
much yeah you're raising money and
awareness for the Georgia campaign for
adolescent power and potential potential
why is this cause so important to you
well I started it I founded it 28 years
ago
um at a time when Georgia had the
highest rate of teen pregnancy yes and
parenting when a young person and I met
kids that were 10
11 12 who were having babies
very hard to
take advantage of opportunities that
come along
if you're young and you have a baby teen
pregnancy has dropped here 73 percent
and I can't say that that's all gcap
gcap though is the only organization in
Georgia that has kept this issue on the
front on the front burner the
organization has evolved to of course
focus on teen pregnancy but also the
mental health aspect that that is so
important to deal with today talk a
little bit about that as well the
pandemic the covid pandemic took a toll
on mental health for adults as well as
young people but it's really hit young
people to that together with the climate
crisis
I mean
kids are very they're in Despair and
they're angry
that us adults haven't been able to do
anything to make sure that they will
have a livable future when young people
become advocates for issues it it's a
great antidote to Despair and so we have
our youth advisory councils we have our
youth advocacy but also even
comprehensive sexuality education that
we've brought into many many many school
districts in Georgia do you also have a
lot of celebrity friends how important
is that that everyone collaborates to
move the issues forward well For Better
or Worse celebrities bring attention to
a subject matter
and um you know I'm not going to be
around for much longer and we we need to
get celebrities involved in this issue
so they can they can help
you know keep it going now why would you
say you're not going to be around much
longer when you get to be my age you're
you you'd better be aware of the amount
of time that is behind you as opposed to
in front of you I mean that's just
realistic I'm not afraid of going I'm
ready I've had a great life not that I
want to go but I'm aware that it's it's
going to be sooner rather than later and
you've said you're a reluctant icon why
reluctant I don't know why I said that
I I don't know I mean I think the word
is bandied about too easily I don't know
if I'm an icon you know but I'll take it
I mean it's better than a kick in the
ass I wish that's happened to me too
[Music]